toi seulement en espagnol
Oh
à
qui me l'aurait dit il y a longtemps
quand c'était neuf
qu'entre s'aimer et s'aimer
il y a un secret
et ce n'est pas que je me sens bizarre
de cette manière
je ne veux pas dire
pas de honte
C'est juste un cri d'amour que je ne connais pas
se termine là
un univers qui revient n'est jamais oublié
je suis tombé amoureux je suis tombé amoureux je suis tombé amoureux de
en t'ayant je suis tombé amoureux
Te faire un câlin
Je pensais que ce serait peu
à propos de te trouver
Je pensais que ce serait le cas 5
et il y a tellement de choses qui font mal et il y en a
à tel point que ça part
commencer la journée avec toi
et retomber amoureux
seulement un mystère qui ne finit pas et qui
revient
une averse d'amour qui ne regrette pas
je suis tombé amoureux, je suis tombé amoureux
Je suis tombé amoureux de toi
tomber amoureux
Je suis tombé amoureux de te serrer dans mes bras
Je suis tombé amoureux
dorer
Merci beaucoup
Mercier bombé